we're joined in studio by cbs news chief
election and campaign correspondent
that's robert costa bob i'm so excited
to see you in person thank you so much
for being here we just heard merrick
garland say no one no one bob is above
the law
is he signaling something should we read
anything into that what does this
investigation mean ultimately for the
former president well great to be here
with you all cbs news has learned that
questions are being asked about former
president trump's conduct during the
final days of the administration what
was he doing with conservative lawyer
john eastman rudy giuliani to try to
upend and overturn the 2020 election
we're still not sure if trump is going
to be a criminal target of any justice
department investigation but the
pressure is mounting congresswoman liz
cheney told me she and others believe
inside congress that there was a
conspiracy here to overturn the election
the challenge for garland is is criminal
intent provable at this point but they
are having a grand jury investigation to
see where it all goes
well
president trump is making or at least
he's he's leading us all to believe that
he's going to run again i think that
remains to be seen should he still be
considered the leader of the republican
party despite all of the chatter and
swirl around him much of it negative
great question he certainly wants to be
when you talk to his allies but it's not
clear he is going to remain the standard
bearer for the republican party so many
other rising stars in the gop governor
glenn younkin of virginia florida
governor ron desantis they're making
moves toward possible 2024 runs that's
in part why trump is getting out there
now not announcing but giving these big
speeches he wants to potentially freeze
the field stop others from gaining
traction so this is uncharted territory
for the justice department i spoke to
former attorney general eric holder and
asked him if you were the attorney
general would you have indicted would
you indict former president trump he
said yes because no one is above the law
but it does set a dangerous precedent
what are you hearing it's a complicated
and charged legal and political question
on one side there are even some
democrats who privately worry about the
way this could all tear at the civic
fabric but there's also a question of
what would it mean if he didn't
prosecute should he believe there was
criminal conduct that took place inside
the white house that also could tear at
this nation's civic fabric if people
felt trump somehow got away with
something but they keep calling it
partisan and they keep saying which hunt
donald trump says but many of the people
were testifying are republicans who were
his allies who were key people in his
administration what sense are you
getting about their perception of trump
his his political peers
well you know that right now former penn
states like mark short and his lawyer
greg jacob they are going before a grand
jury that's serious business and they're
telling the truth under oath to justice
department prosecutors about what
happened it's significant that the
justice department is moving closer to
trump we've paid so much attention to
the congressional side of this the
january 6 committee but at the end of
the day it's the justice department that
will likely have the biggest impact on
this whole story
bob thank you so much it's good having
you in studio with you